منذ اعلان روسيا عدم تمديد العمل باتفاق
نحق للحبوب اصبح البحر الاسود ساحه لتبادل
الضربات والاستهداف بين الجانبين ميناء
اوديسا وميناء اسماعيل ومنشات تخزين حبوب
تعرضت اكثر من مره لضربات روسيه بالمسيرات
والصواريخ دمرت الاف الاطنان من الحبوب
وفق الروايات الاوكرانيه بينما قالت روسيا
ان ضربات استهدفت منشات عسكريه اوكرانيه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت بدايه هذا
الشهر ان سفونها الحربيه دمرت زورقا مسيرا
تابعا للبحريه الاوكرانيه حاول مهاجمه
سفينه حربيه روسيه كانت ترافق سفينه نقل
مدنيه في البحر الاسود بعد يومين ذكرت
وكاله رويترز للانباء ان البحريه
الاوكرانيه استهدفت سفينه ايزال روسيه في
خليج نوفو روسسك وان سفينه تضررت ولم تعد
قادره على تنفيذ مهام قتاليه في حين اعلنت
روسيا تدمير زورقي حاول الهجوم على قاعده
في 13 من اغسطس ابا الماضي اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها نفذت انزالا على
سفينه شحن متجهه الى ميناء اسماعيل
الاوكراني وان سفينه الشحن تابعه او تابعت
مسارها نحو الميناء بعد انتهاء التفتيش